you're sitting in the middle of a
cheering crowd the arena around you
is electric fans hollering from their
seats as they watch the basketball game
every point scored every shot missed and
every skillful pass of the ball sends
waves of excitement over everyone in the
audience
applause shouts and chants fill the air
it distracts you for a moment
you find yourself swept up in the energy
of the game
but slowly surely a nagging feeling
creeps up on you as your eyes follow
the ball that feeling turns to a
sickening realization
as one of the players jumps and dunks
the basketball scoring another
two points you notice the look on his
face
the same look on the faces of all the
other players on the court
a solemn hopeless expression it's the
same look of silent despair
worn by all the spectators around you
then you remember
you've watched this exact game of
basketball before
many many times before and that is when
you feel the same
hopeless expression appear on your own
face
realizing just how long you have been
here
watching this game over and over
reminded that you will never ever
leave this arena welcome to scp-1733
to the untrained eye as cp 1733 seems to
be a completely harmless item
stored in a digital video recorder it is
kept securely in the dusty depths of the
scp foundation's video archives
if any researcher is given permission to
study scp-1733
they will find it to be an ordinary vhs
tape but what about the contents of said
tape
does it contain a bizarre disconnected
series of black and white video clips
that when viewed only give the watcher
seven days before the spirit of a
drowned girl comes crawling out of their
tv screen to kill them
well not exactly but we're sure that if
such a tape exists
the foundation probably has it under
lock and key too
the footage on scp-1733 is as seemingly
banal as the ordinary vhs tape itself
when played the viewer will witness a tv
broadcast of a basketball game
specifically the 2010-2011 nba season
opener
broadcast on television and captured on
tape by an unknown civilian
the game took place on the 26th of
october 2010
in the td garden arena in boston
massachusetts
a game where the hometown boston celtics
took on the miami heat
by now perhaps you are wondering what is
so special about this particular game
and why the scp foundation would be so
interested in keeping a vhs recording of
it so
secure is one of the o5 council secretly
a celtics fan
well that's impossible to say for sure
what we do know for certain is that
scp-1733 is far more than just a
harmless recording of a basketball game
the scp foundation first caught wind of
scp-1733's existence the day
after the game on october 27th a boston
native that had watched and recorded the
game made comments on social media
about a technical foul that the game's
referee had failed to pick up on
according to this individual during the
third quarter an instance of
unsportsmanlike conduct took place
between ray allen
and chris bosh the person making these
claims was quickly ridiculed by
commenters on the same thread
but then this person uploaded a clip of
this foul from the footage they had
recorded
the other commenters were dumbfounded
during the original broadcast
that foul had never happened but the
recording showed it clear
as day the footage was quickly expunged
and all traces of the clip removed from
the internet by personnel acting on
behalf of the scp
foundation any that had viewed the video
on facebook
or been a part of the comments debating
this previously non-existent foul
were tracked down via their ip addresses
all of them including the owner of the
tape were given amnestics to wipe their
memories of the supposed
infraction and scp-1733 was returned to
the foundation for further
analysis researchers at the foundation
were determined to understand the
anomalous nature of scp-1733
and why the footage contained on this
particular vhs tape was so
different from the basketball game's
original broadcast
at first the differences in the game
seem to be only slight changes from the
one that actually aired on tv
a different vowel here a small point
difference there
while the recording of the game
contained on scp-1733 was slightly
different from the real-life game
perhaps even more interesting was that
these differences
changed with repeat viewings researchers
wouldn't observe the same differences
every time they watched scp-1733
but would instead spot something
different that had been
changed each time they restarted the
tape
and as they continued to watch and
re-watch scp-1733's footage
the true horror of the video's anomalous
properties became
more and more apparent as the footage
recorded on scp-1730
began to diverge more and more from the
original broadcast
researchers shifted their attention away
from the basketball game itself
and on to the people watching it just
like the specifics of the game itself
the fans in the arena seemed to also
change with every re-watch of the tape
and even stranger the people in the
crowd seemed to not only be aware of
their existence within the footage
but also retain memories of every
previous replayed vision
each time the researchers had watched
scp-1733
the audience trapped within had gained
more and more cognizance
every man woman and child in the
audience of that basketball game began
remembering that they had seen multiple
variations
of the same game over and over
again this first became apparent to
foundation researchers when the game's
commentators two presenters named mike
and tommy
began to comment on a strange sense of
deja vu they were experiencing
as they watched the boston celtics and
miami heat play
both seemed to share notions that the
game they were witnessing was strangely
familiar
and in later replays of the tape these
two commentator personalities were able
to recall the events of the game
with perfect vivid accuracy while they
never addressed the viewer directly
this cumulative effect seems to have
extended to every person that was
present within the arena at the time
that the original broadcast was recorded
everyone from the commentators to the
coaches the players to the patrons
all remember the diverging versions of
the basketball game
but seem to have no awareness that they
are trapped inside a recording
on a vhs tape it should be noted that it
is still
unclear whether the entities are real
people or digital copies that solely
reside on the tape
every individual shown to be inside td
garden on the 26th of october 2010
seems to be identical to their
counterparts in the real world
each of the basketball players on both
the boston celtics and miami heat teams
have the exact same level of talent as
they do in reality
and their individual mannerisms are
perfectly recreated
in the scp-1733 footage and the same is
true of the fans in the audience
each one appearing to be in every
conceivable way
a living human being but the most
unnerving aspect of scp-1733 was found
when the foundation
agents were tasked with tracking down
members of the audience who were seen on
the tape
and they found nothing unlike the
players and coaches who can
quite easily be found in our world with
many of them still playing or involved
with professional basketball
personnel were unable to find a single
trace of any of the people from the
audience
not one clue as to their current
whereabouts or
status it is unclear how but it appears
that everyone shown on scp-1733
especially those watching the game
unfold from the stands
is a person trapped in digital form
stuck watching variations of the same
match
on loop researchers at the scp
foundation who were studying
scp-1733 initially theorized that the
tape had been designed to display an
infinite variety of different game
outcomes given that the tactics utilized
by the players were different with each
playback of scp-1733
this seemed to be the case that the tape
was showing a what-if scenario
each time the tape was rewound and
played from the start
but the scenario wasn't resetting each
time it was clear
that they were learning by the 34th
replay of the footage
the boston celtics and miami heat were
so in tune with the opposing team's
playbook
that both sides players were able to
perfectly and precisely counter their
opponent's moves
and kept the score at 0-0 for much
of the game at this stage in the
foundation's research
the players on the scp-1733 tape had not
yet become fully aware
that they had played the same game
already in earlier playbacks
but it is possible that weak memories of
the earlier versions of the same match
manifested as instinctive ways players
could counter the moves of their rival
team
however by the time foundation
researchers had replayed the
footage 45 times the players their
coaches and
fans watching the game had become aware
of what was happening to them
it was at this point that the digital
recording from td garden changed
dramatically
realizing that they'd been playing the
same game of basketball over and over
the players refused to participate any
longer everyone in the audience began to
attempt to escape from the tape where
they'd been
unknowingly imprisoned but not a single
one of the stadium's doors would budge
and neither the fans nor the players
seemed to be able to leave
through any other exit out of td garden
over the following playbacks of the
scp-1733 videotape
attempts at escape grew increasingly
daring in one playback a full-scale riot
broke out
in another makeshift explosives were
built and used by those trapped to try
and blast their way
to freedom as their cognition grew and
they began to remember
friends and family from outside the
videotape the crowd trapped in scp-1733
grew
even more desperate players and their
coaches retired to locker rooms
withdrawing from the crowd for a time
the rest of the people in the footage
began to form factions amongst
themselves
one of the more prominent calling
themselves the faith keepers
these individuals voiced their belief
that they had been confined to td garden
as some form of spiritual punishment
as a result of the consumerism that is
rife in a post-industrial society the
faith keepers began burning offerings in
the center of the basketball court
phones wallets car keys anything that
reminded them of the modern
world over the subsequent playbacks of
scp-1733
the faith keepers grew in their numbers
indoctrinating more of the crowd into
their movement
those still trying to escape from the
stadium were causing more damage to
themselves than their enclosure
with three men caught in the blast of
another crude bomb placed on an exit
door unfortunately for them the door
barely showed a scratch in the aftermath
of the detonation as foundation
researchers continued replaying the tape
those trapped within scp-1733 descended
into depraved acts and incidences of
violence became
rampant some even attempted to take
their own lives and acts of desperation
jumping from balconies in the hopes of
ending the loop
those that had joined the growing ranks
of the faith keepers did not engage in
such behavior
instead creating makeshift curtains to
separate themselves from the breakdown
that was taking place among the others
trapped within the scp-1733
tank at some point beyond the 112th
playback of the videotape
the faith keepers marched off scream and
brought the basketball teams back out
onto the main court
they then began a ritualistic sacrifice
disemboweling the professional athletes
for their fellow prisoners to see
this had no noticeable effect with the
recording of the game resetting as it
had done
in earlier re-watches in a later
playback
the faith keepers then began to call for
all the children in the stadium to be
sacrificed
in the same way testing on scp-1733 was
finally suspended
indefinitely after this point and as far
as we know
the crowd remains trapped inside the
anomalous recording of this particular
celtics heat basketball game
foundation researchers have been unable
to produce the same anomalous effects as
those of scp-1733
even when using the dvr that originally
produced the recording
the digital video recorder itself does
not seem to imprint the same properties
onto other vhs
tapes making scp-1733
an isolated anomaly however the next
time you find yourself in a basketball
game
it might be worth asking yourself have i
seen this game before
now check out scp-1861 the crew of the
hms wintershimer
and scp-1337 the hitchhiker
for more chilling tales from the scp
foundation